welcome to the app clinic at the
brand-new time of 1030am mountain view
time lutely my name is reto Meier and
I'm still asleep but if I were awake I
would be Ian knee Lewis excellent and
today we're going to take a look at
photography and camera apps in the App
clinic we've got a good range of apps to
look at in fact these are them we've got
IM picsart glimmer and camera zoom FX
I've really been looking forward to
these right hooks I know we're both
photographers or i should say you're a
photographer and i own a camera i think
it's probably fair to say i also own a
camera actually our erstwhile engineer
mr. Daniel Pham is probably I think I
think it's fair to say a photographer
that's quite sure he takes all the
pictures for our our promotional videos
that's true and in fact I was so
confident in his ability that the photos
that we're going to look at I actually
sent them around this morning with our
demo device to take some photos of stuff
so we would have some decent example
axolotls and just to be clear a demo
device today is a Galaxy Nexus it isn't
yes all right hey I don't want to
disappoint you guys but I really just
took photos of the studio so maybe the
viewers will have you know a good time
looking at some behind-the-scenes photos
of you know how messy it really is in
here all right well I assume that
they're gonna be highly artistic and and
well filtered photos of our studio so uh
I got right I guess officially kick off
so do it as per usual we're going to go
through each of the apps give them sort
of a final two to five minute overview
before having a look at what we think
are the keys to making a really great
camera and photography app and some of
some links to some developer resources
that should help you to be able to take
your app to that next level so let's
start off with IM and this is a team
that has actually worked with with some
of our developer advocates over in
London I think rich Hyndman or intimate
however we decided to say his name today
has been working with these guys and
giving them some advice so let's uh
let's take a look and see how it works
absolutely by the way I noticed the QR
codes are back check that out indeed
Dana someone always complains when we
don't have
QR codes this is true yeah getting used
to it now yeah I noticed that our chroma
keying is slightly off as well so we
don't have quite the background that we
should bear but oh is that what happened
I thought maybe you just chose to to
leave it rid of them make us Roman was
you know that's true but Roman is a
trendsetter and you know I don't think
I'm quite a bit that's true we are
always following room in fact all I did
you know so I did the the intro video
for today by the way thank you it's all
it's all Roman Romans artwork excellent
so if we can switch to the to the phone
shot and we'll take a look at say now
there you go yeah so this is this is M
so we've as you can see folks we have
removed the backwards facing camera and
we're doing hdmi chroma keying was
almost right no not going to work hi
guys I'm trying that's all right well we
will let you continue to do that so but
what you got up here is I am so what it
is is basically what you'd expect it to
an app which lets you take photographs
lets you apply filters to them and has a
community for sharing those photos with
your friends I think particularly on
Twitter and Facebook it's got the links
for that directly so you can see here
your front page is basically what you
would expect it's sort of a rolling list
view of of all of the photos that your
friends have taken and one of the things
which which they're done quite well here
is they've got these tabs these tab
labels that you can see here yeah and so
you know as people tagging them you can
go oh actually I'd be interested to see
more photos from san benedetto del
tronto you click that and it will take
you to a bunch of other things show you
want a map where it's at and all the
other photos that is very cool yeah I
quite like that so this this pass is a
big test of mine which is you know can
you get lost in the app you're going to
spend a lot of time just going all cool
i want to see more of those sorts of
photos and rona sorts of people one of
the really key features of this app
which I really wanted to highlight is
that they've done a really good job on
the UI of the actual picture display and
you can see here they've got this
heterogeneous list view or grid view I
suppose it is and you can see here we've
got different sized images all coming
together to create something which is
quite compelling
to look at Nagaina can sort of click
three weeks right now this isn't a
particularly well accelerated list via
though it feels a little janky yeah yeah
so that's one thing so you know Danny
options actually been working for about
a year on on some new techniques for
doing faster ListView rendering for
photos and hopefully one of these days
we'll actually get that released yeah
this is a nice shot this is the the
Googleplex although it says grand quest
46 it's not let's googolplex 44 right
and and in fact we are in the room just
above the honeycomb that's right just
here we're in here so you can wave to us
if you here at the right time we would
love to have people holding signs
outside the window yeah be kind of cool
we're on the second floor so that I
would be insanely cool if they were
right outside the window what you think
our fans don't own ladders do you think
they don't have the dedication it takes
I see them they own jetpacks don't have
fans mmm maybe a problem so wait I'll
tell you the first thing that strikes me
about this app I is this button down
here mom it looks like maybe that's how
I'm gonna take a picture it is okay and
you can see I think if you're on a
different phone maybe a galaxy s ii or
something you would think this is a
pretty cool design once you get on to
one of these no button phones you
realize this is actually kind of a bad
idea that looks very very nice to you
home button it's very close to the home
button it's very similar to the action
that you're going to use to bring up
Google down there's a lot of things that
you can screw up with the camera run
here and that's as we mentioned before
that's one of the reasons that we sort
of discourage tabs on the bottom because
you know you can very easily get mixed
up with that bottom row of buttons
absolutely so and of course they do also
have a menu button down and this is the
confusing thing because they have
something which looks a lot like an
action bar which has a menu button and
if you click that you do get an overflow
menu but and so they've done this thing
where you've still got the menu button
and that brings up you know I wonder if
there I wonder if they're using
something like actionbarsherlock and
then they're not setting the API level
high enough because we actually don't
document this career
Lee it's changed since the docks for
release you can't absolutely guarantee
that that thing will go away until your
API level is 15 yeah and we had
originally said 11 okay yeah to make
sure it's up to it yeah 14 but let's
make it 15 and just be safe mm-hmm so
that's one thing you can get rid of that
really easily because it'll come back on
for devices which which don't have you
know which do have a hard menu button
okay so the other call out that I wanted
to mention here is that they have
implemented the drawer pattern i'm
pretty sure they're aware that this
isn't quite the right drawer pattern but
i wanted to put it out there for other
people who may be watching yeah this is
calling sort of that prototype G+ model
where the action bar all shifts across
and you can see that here so
everything's moved across the right
model is actually the way youtube
doesn't which is that your action bar is
is consistent so all the all the stuff
here along your action bar they should
stay here no matter what and rather have
than having sort of a drawer icon you
would have your application icon or logo
with an upper fords and so they're
clicking that will then leave everything
here as it is and then just have this
side part here slide-out so in the same
way but still having the action bar
along the top and I think you know so
that's that's kind of the right way to
do it that's all listed in the design
patterns on Android design yeah and
again it's not that these guys got it
wrong it's that there wasn't a design
pattern and now there is if they
followed an example which turns out we
decided wasn't quite the right example
all right so now I'll tell you this is
driving me crazy because I tell you so
we've got we have two options you can
scoot over or we can move the camera
that's good oh okay overheats Peppa does
not want to move the camera lead the
camera alone Ian yeah exactly I fixed it
last week and now it's bad he's not
please don't touch my stuff alrighty so
otherwise you know things things here
work as you'd expect you have the
ability to to like nice little animation
comes up there you can add comments you
know they've got a pretty custom UI here
with their own custom buttons but it's
consistent throughout there's a color
scheming there's a design ethos here
which I think works it passes that is it
different yes does it still look good
yes let's
he probably would like to see you know
so what what it under Charenton yes
probably would have liked to see the
actual share button that's you know
that's something that I think people are
getting used to and as we use that more
it it becomes a consistent way to say i
want to share something I that's
agnostic to services or you know what's
hot this way I mean you know if I think
we've said it before if this phone had
been designed five years ago everybody
would have myspace buttons slowly and
and we'd all feel like fools wouldn't we
the other thing is what is flag
inappropriate things oh I see okay watch
it I need to like it for nudity yeah
exactly there is a naked Android right
there all right yeah and I love this the
the animation that you got to work that
this is a problem when you have touch
targets which are less than 48 pixels
people have trouble hitting small finger
great Oh wins again so the only thing
that i sort of miss is I feel like I'd
like to see that carried out everywhere
show it's always so sad when you see a
beautiful user interface and it's been
lovingly crafted and then you get to the
point where like the world ends and
everything stops and you realize they
ran out of time and it's just a normal
Android system dialogue and it's not
just Android that does this you know
I've got plenty of apps on my pc that do
this but i think that you know for
especially for an app like this that's
all about beauty it's worth taking the
extra time to make sure that the entire
interface follows whatever design theme
you've chosen whether that's the stock
android design or something completely
different all right so let's have a
quick look at the phone taking
functionality before moving on so we'll
start using the camera because otherwise
it starts to get a little bit confusing
oh yeah it does work nice oh wow that's
awesome boom yeah that's a winner that's
your new uh that's near my new album
covers absolutely no I guess that's a
tick yep no it's just a mole yeah and so
we can go through here and apply all of
the the usual hipster filters let's see
if we can make you even more jaundiced
because I think that's kind of awesome
there we go yeah that's a win so kind of
the what you would expect except that it
kind of stopped there so that's a bug
let's so let's report that to the guys
so that they are there can be any think
they're things absolutely what build are
you running on this whatever the latest
public retails yeah all right so let's
uh let's let's move on so that's that's
I am really popular I've got a lot of
great comments on the moderator link for
that one so we will be returning to this
later on when we look at the
prescriptions for a great app but
definitely a good start let's take a
look at Pixar let's glue in picsart all
right open that up
so right off the bat we get the follow
us on Twitter so this doesn't come up
every time the activity launches but it
comes up often enough to be a pain Polly
because all you have there is a follow
button and you can get back to tube to
cancel it but there were kind of anti
dialogues to begin with Fred we're kind
of anti forcing people to do things you
know to help verify your own brand you
know kind of go write me in the store
five stars that sort of thing and follow
us on twitter by all means have a
twitter account which people can follow
for news but sort of trying to force
them to do so it's kind of overly
attached girlfriend mean it's like
following me no this isn't cool like
people will find it make it easy for
them to do it but you know you know need
quite that much validation yeah actually
yeah it is it is a little desperate ok
so they've got this nice like what do we
call this like a city UI or some sort of
urban you wanna area you I something
like that yeah so you know it's it's an
interesting it's an interesting pattern
I probably would have may be taken out
some of these it makes it that makes it
kind of busy there's a lot going on yeah
reminds me a little of yeah it's a shop
it's interesting but in general really
nice and the colors are amazing right
right yeah ok so what can you do with
Pixar can you do so let's say let's have
a flick through so basically it's a CAD
data that's just that's just lies so
basically it's a combination of a few
different kinds of camera ads so you can
take your photos and ye hipster filters
excuse me which we will do once again
let's try and get let's get down
there we go very nice so you can take
your photos and apply your hipster
filters as you would as you would
normally expect that it's got a good
selection of you know different standard
things and you can actually do quite a
lot here in terms of applying different
kinds of presets eventually maybe it
does seem to be taking a long time but I
do like there there little rotating
status bar yeah well this is one of
those things to where they're obviously
not using the stock android or but but
it is part of their branding exactly and
you know i know we harp on this a lot
but we get this question a lot you know
people will bring us an app that uses
some let's call a spade a spade
sometimes they'll pull in assets
directly from the iphone and windows
mobile and they'll say well that's just
the way our designers like it and I
think that's not really cool let me
first off is not Android but second off
it's not yours it's somebody else's
stuff that's right but when you take
something that Android provides and then
make it completely your so it works
exactly the same has a little cycling
mmm color so you know what's going on
but has your branding in it I think
that's great I wish that more apps would
do that so and then you get the
advantage of having that consistency
across all the versions of your app and
everything else now we also have the
very consistent to yet this should be a
built in control right now the hitters
drip I mean they've actually got like a
bunch of different ones so they've got
the standard effects that you're
applying there and you can you could
actually modify the degree of each of
these which is nice as well see apply
that and I think you can then go through
and apply a bunch of different kinds of
filters so they've got the distortion
filters they've got you know all any of
those different things I think it's
really interesting that compared to so
many other apps or looked odds this app
is really slow mmm at applying filters
and I wonder if it's because they're not
taking advantage of acceleration in in
android especially in honeycomb and
above you can use renderscript or you
can use the GPU to accelerate this sort
of thing this is most of these filters
just boil down to convolutions of one
kind or another so you can I and Java is
just not
go to convolutions at all its memory
layout is wrong it doesn't have access
to simdi floating point instructions I
don't even think it has access to
non-strict floating point instructions
which means you're going to be abiding
by I Tripoli standards and getting into
all sorts of performance problems so you
really really really don't want to write
your your filter code in Java or even in
just generic C++ you really want to be
using neon or for the best compatibility
actually just write it in OpenGL yeah
absolutely so that's um will click
through so we've all seen this sort of
thing beforehand so the hit okay then
you have a bunch of options you can
either upload it to picsart save to the
SD card tweeted export it a whole bunch
of things now personally I would kind of
prefer if it just did something sensible
by default maybe save it to the SD card
and then take me back to a page where it
just displays all the things that I've
saved and allow me to share or add to a
time on or whatever from there rather
than asking for this explicit fare well
and this seems like a lot of people get
this wrong in a mobile app and retail
you had a great talk about this at
Google i/o you have the opportunity to
make your app work like magic forget
about saving and loading and knowing
what file paths are and all sorts of
things like that if you look at good
mobile apps they just always work they
do what the user probably wants and they
give the user a way to back out if it's
not what they wanted so it shouldn't be
about saving it should be about deleting
things that have already been saying
because everything gets saves exactly
you know you don't have this problem
anymore where you've got a totally
really really limited amount of storage
in one or two extra photos is going to
kill you you can take a lot of photos
before it's a problem yeah you know back
in the day where you know back in the
dose day is the only thing you had to
identify a file was its follow and its
extension and so then you had to create
these complex hierarchical folder
structures in order to be able to find
anything so you basically creating
metadata out of your file system these
days you can use the metadata you can
display the photo so you can go with us
I daresay almost no one knows or cares
what the file names are for their photos
now exactly particularly not on your on
your mobile where so this is all a bit
confusing I've already saved it and it
just took me back here
so I'm just going to close and assume
that it's kept it somewhere good luck
yeah so then it takes us back to the
foetus we can continue taking photos or
back again so they've done their own
kind of camera view too yeah they've got
one I'm gonna live spot yeah I'm I'm not
as excited about this just because I
feel like this isn't quite as much their
branding I mean it I I look at these
icons and I'm like yeah I think I've
seen those somewhere but yeah and
they're really small they really are not
particularly high res either I can see a
little bit of mess around some of the
vector art well Galaxy Nexus is always a
good test case for finding out if you've
got the right resources because it's a
720p phone not a same thing for I think
galaxy s3 galaxy s2 or the same
resolution so it's an extremely high
resolution display and if you're just
thinking to yourself oh these these
things look good on a 4-inch display
that's not always true if you're on this
one of these xhdpi devices so the other
thing I want to point out real quick is
that you're hiding my status bar which
is a pain because we may have been going
on for 15 minutes about this app and I
don't know so please don't please please
I beg if you do not hide my status bar I
want to know what time it is i want to
see my emails coming in that is actually
more important than your lap if you must
hide the status bar at least let me tap
and get it back yeah look it's fine if
you've got like a gallery view and I
want to look at my photos in full screen
and flick through it sure but you know
give me that tap ability to get for this
back a couple apps that do this really
well are the e-readers so Google Play
Books amazon kindle both have really
good status bar hiding and showing
functionality i'm gonna see if we can
get data so hey come on ok so we've got
some here so we can see this is the
community aspect of it this is this is
less less janky in terms of the scroll
but we're still seeing a reasonable
amount of time taken to load each of the
pictures here well it's tough to they
get around that right because we've
gotten we've got network latency we've
got the decoding
you know these are probably not small
bitmaps and that's out of the question
here is like you know and and you can
see actually once what's things end up
in cash yes keeping it in which is nice
I I think that of of the apps i've
looked at these these guys are doing
exactly the right thing I mean you can't
you can't you know overcome the laws of
physics but really are you just not
trying hard enough yeah well they're
they're trying pretty hard actually um
this does feel pretty good it's very
hard to see on on the video on YouTube
but this is an extremely smooth
scrolling experience the flinging feels
just right so the rock physics it's yeah
it's all good so yeah Bravo you click
through and so this is a good experience
you know you're swiping Swiper left ride
you can see here the physics are right
it's it's moving at the same speed as my
finger but then I can just do a quick
flick and it it feels about right so
that's done a good job and they've got
the the pinch to zoom and then it's
always an interesting question what do
you do once you've pinch-to-zoom get to
the edge um but this seems fine I like
that yeah I got here once I get to the
edge of the picture as long as I'm able
to take it back and undo my swipe across
I think that's the right approach I'm
actually wondering if there's any
chances these guys were actually using
danielle pans library because it does
exactly this as possible days or maybe
seeing this and used it as a basis quite
possibly yeah yeah yeah I think that
these guys are doing everything right as
far as yeah the physics there a little
bit it's a little funny once you're a
bouncing home it's too much fun for this
time of day and again we've kind of got
the this is interesting so now we've got
the the menu button on the action bar
here but they've still got the legacy
button down here and that does
absolutely nothing so that's now
confusing because it's ambiguous yeah
you know so at the very least I mean
really the right solution here is get
rid of this I'll set your target SDK to
15 you know at the very 16 now yeah
exactly should always be the latest
version that's a good tip for you guys
as well as always talk with the latest
k there's really no reason not to avoid
right the only possible reason not to is
if you have no confidence that your app
works on the latest SDK and you're
unable to test on any new device or new
emulator so I would have sympathy with
let's say hardcore video ABS that are
trying to do streaming that's only been
supported recently um and it's still a
little buggy but in general you're you I
should should support the latest SDK
yeah alright so let's let's jump out of
this because not actually show how much
time we've spent but let's have a look
at at glimmer so glimmers a little bit
different this is not your sort of
standard camera replacement app this is
actually an app to browse flicker so in
terms of functionality much more
simplistic here we basically you know
you sign into your flickr account and
then you can scroll through all the
pictures nice what does Daniel Pham have
to say about racers oh right oh yeah it
looks like you know how to potty yeah
that was actually I i/o last year not
this year but that's actually right cuz
this year was trained nobody was
partying I was close enough to Dave
Navarro's late Donal's reach out grab
him I decided that was probably not a
good at you decided that that would
probably be a problem considering the
restraining order yes right well yeah so
for those of you who didn't make it to 0
this is what it'll feature eyes on some
of these shots it's mr. Galvin yeah oh
yeah without his beard beardless
galloping yeah that's a little scary it
is but the master is having a party
tonight HM pizza overall it's a nice
effect again you've got the nice smooth
swiping between between items you've got
the standard action bar along the top
here which behaves in the way that it
should you've got the Refresh icon which
works in place again probably no need
for an explicit refresh as an a primary
action just because the photos are going
to be updating that quickly you can
probably get away with coming up with
some sort of sensible refresh model now
you know what I love about this app
place this page right here this is
exactly what a photos
now oriented list for you should look
like look at this Avery they've done
already know just it's all images
they've overlaid text that looks nice
it's big enough it's a readable you know
now one thing that I haven't seen I
haven't seen any photo that is just
really really bad for for text well
there's there's one um thank you but you
can see they've yeah they've overlaid
some could be a little darker on this
one big yeah exactly and that's that's
the whole idea really is you say you
make the photo everything don't don't
put you know little drop shadows behind
it don't put you know bars between it
don't shrink the photo down so it's
thumbnail size this just looks beautiful
exactly i mean there's all kinds of
things here and you straight away you
can see we're like you know you can tell
from a photo even from this relatively
small portion on the weather it's
something you're going to be interested
in exactly more often i think they've
done a great job the only disappointing
thing is it feels like they're cashing
isn't quite as good as the last time can
see here as soon as you sort of get more
than sort of hafez might be on the page
you're looking at you you've got the
white that is understandable though I
mean the viewpager is sort of set up to
do that and you have to really go out of
your way to do cash management if you're
if you want to serve lots and lots of
images very quickly I mean one thing you
can do as well which you know maybe
maybe it issue here is make sure that
you are downloading different sized
images as well so obviously going to
have the double hit if you click on it
and then you have to download the full
size image but at least you're dealing
with a smaller memory footprint faster
downloads faster load times those sorts
of things now right after that all of a
sudden I'm sort of disappointed because
ooh text moon right right it's a shame
no of course I mean this is this is for
your flickr groups i guess and obviously
the the photos are maybe less important
but i would argue that I mean if it were
linked in I'd be like yeah photos
whatever its flickers there you're not
there for anything else exactly so it
feels like you could do the same thing
here we're just taking that the image
associated with the group make that your
full background and then maybe because
there's more text and it's more
important you you know / lane
more of that on top of the text but when
you've got images like you look at the
way magazines work right like the big
advantage of magazines is that you've
got you know rich color full full color
and adapts like this if you have the
pictures user because it's awesome yeah
so this is looking pretty good we don't
have the hipster filters to go through
so I think maybe we move on to the to
the next appt the last one which we're
going to look at today we can resume
resume effects so this is again sort of
so this is just your hipster filters and
it's locked into landscape view which we
decided to leave this way to kind of
prove a point which is I don't always
want to take my photos and landscape
view through so you know your UI
particularly you can see here this is
basically an entirely a custom camera
you want they've drawn all about
themselves right so there's really no
reason here why they can't rotate the
assets right absolutely and even these
days like I remember back in the days of
Android 1.1 you you had to take photos
in landscape mode because there was no
way of knowing what orientation the
camera was at that's that changed a long
time ago now so you can actually query
the device to find out what the
orientation camera is and rotate things
so that they're sort of in the right
aspect ratio perspective it's also worth
asking yourself if you really really
need to do a custom camera view because
whenever you duplicate system
functionality you risk looking out of
date once the system updates and in
particular you're going to miss out on
any brand new functionality that the
system gives you now for this you know
maybe maybe they've got some really cool
camera stuff going on the problem is
that a lot of the coolest camera
technology in Android is being supplied
by OEM libraries so
you may be missing out on something
really really slick if you completely
override the camera it's interesting if
I hit front-facing it doesn't do
anything so it may be a bug yeah well
that's that's what you get right it's
certainly freezing um did yeah it did it
just freeze do you think or no its back
okay can't you take a walk um so the
only reason I can think of that you want
to build a custom camera and then do the
preview yourself is if you really need
to do live preview so do these guys do
library I believe what they do yeah if
you get the if you start it up and hit
the effects button I believe you're able
to apply okay let's have a look um all
right let's easy maybe this is coloring
or Brandon effects all right oh here
vignette vignettes always good okay yes
they're going that in real time you can
see that on the edge thing right um but
you'll notice that a lot of the effects
that you want are actually disabled hmm
in in the real-time mode yeah yeah which
isn't surprising it's actually in ICS we
improve things and jelly bean we
improved them even more I think there's
one extra step that that the GL team is
talking about it but we've
systematically been reducing the number
of operations that it takes to do a live
preview with effects so originally it
was extremely tedious and you had to
bring things through java now there's a
single copy involved if you're doing the
GPU acceleration on your effects and in
the future at some point we don't know
exactly when but the team thinks that
they can get that down 20 copies so
you'll be able to go directly from the
camera to the GPU to whatever without
passing through user mode code at all
that's excellent yeah like the app which
I've seen which really does the
most intensive real-time effects is I
think paper camera they do a pretty good
job of this yeah they really do at least
if there are their effects at runtime
which is kind of nice yep and they've
done a lot of work to make that
successful I'm not surprised so that's
that's the basically the way this app
works and it's got all of the standard
filters that you'd expect and you can
apply them to photos either from the
camera or from from your gallery as well
which is nice there's no sort of
community you know picture viewing
sharing functionality built in at least
not that I could find that's a shame
because the share intent is really
really easy to do and it works well for
photos well share they've got so they've
got the standard Sharon tinea okay so
you're just saying that they don't hook
into a little start it up for the first
time and I can't flick through and look
at other photos of people have taken and
shared and that sort of thing which
makes it makes up like Instagram a big
part of that the fence about that
because I on the one hand of like yeah
you're right every time I pick up an app
like that it's really cool on the other
hand like well gee you know don't I have
social networks for that yeah it's true
it's true but you know I kind of like
the the combination particularly if it's
not if the communities is really
simplified so it's not about anything
other than taking a photo and letting
other people see it yeah because then
you kind of get that experience of being
able to to you know interact and share
with people who you know using the same
app taking the same sorts of photos I
think it adds something to it I think
you're right ok cool so that's my saying
again we're hiding this status bar
please stop hiding us out of it all
right beg you yeah just make sure you
have a way to get back that's so
important absolutely because here's the
thing let's say I am completely immersed
in your app and let's say I'm also an
adult with responsibilities if I can get
back to the status bar I can find out
what time it is and I can respond to a
notification I can check my calendar I
can do all these things if not then I
have to leave your app anytime my phone
beeps which is annoying yeah because
some notifications I literally do not
care about but I don't know until I've
looked at the status bar that's right
and you know if you're doing a show like
this you need to know what time it is to
see if you're mad
sively over time which we ordered our
but least we're not actually pass the
end time of our show you which is that's
quite true so let's have a look so we've
been actively sabotaging the show as we
go on yes your carefully yeah okay let's
talk about but less appetizing what are
the prescriptions for camera and date so
this is these are the things that we're
looking for having browse through a
bunch of these apps the things we found
which makes them good we always say that
you can't contradict the the design
guide and that certainly still holds
true here but I think one additional
thing that we want to notice that it
should really look good these are apps
which are targeted at people who like
the way things look photographers design
folks hipsters it's really important
that you create something that's
immediately appealing and you can see
that at the beginning when I showed you
the feature graphics and I meant to
point it out at the time but completely
forgot to they all have feature graphics
they're all really compelling really
really but it you know satin highly
saturated images which look great and so
that's the same sort of thing you want
here you want to make sure that the
entire process is appealing similarly
you want to make sure that the app works
on every image in the gallery and at the
same time works on devices without the
camera so for most of these apps they
allow you to add effects both to live
photos on the camera and do things you
already have on your phone and so I want
that to work on anything I can pick from
the picasa gallery or from the phone
gallery and similarly i wanted to work
on my galaxy nexus i'm sorry on my Nexus
7 even though it has no rear facing
camera I'm not going to use it to take
photos but I have all of my picasa
gallery images synced to it so maybe i
want to you know apply all these filters
on a bigger screen let me do that or you
want to just browse your friends photos
and yeah i think that's actually one of
the one of the biggest problems that we
had when we introduced Nexus 7 was
photography apps that just assumed that
if you didn't have a camera you wouldn't
be interested in a photo app and that's
just not true exactly and obviously want
to have the standard and some unique
hipster filters which I think most of
the apps
we looked at today actually managed to
do to me it's it's not just about
hipster filters it's about ways to make
the photo look good so even if you have
really unique filters one thing that I
think the most successful apps do is a
little bit of automatic tweaking behind
the scenes maybe even without telling
the user just so that you know a little
bit of auto level of auto white balance
to try and make the photos look good
absolutely i mean that's the thing we
all know that we're not expecting to be
able to take great photos with our
camera phones off the back and it's not
an SLR you can't tweak all of your
manual settings and get it just so so
you're looking to concentrate on making
sure you're getting a good shot good
angles good good framing all that sort
of stuff and then having the software
help you make it look like something
that really represents it well
absolutely so let's give you some tips
so the first first tip here is on using
the camera so you've got two options
here which we saw both of which is
either an app which uses the a
completely custom UI which is what
camera zoom FX have done here so you get
that you know you get that completely
custom camera user interface can't find
see save and close again save button so
here you've got the the completely
custom camera user in FS and I think the
first step that we looked at I me by the
way I think that we're we're seeing save
the correct verb uses ID is done yes
that's not a verb but that's the that's
the label you should be using because
there is a case for for having this
inter me like we've talked about this
with alarm apps there is an intermediate
stage where you are working on something
and you don't really feel complete you
don't feel like you know what I'm
setting my alarm I'm doing the hours I
haven't done the minutes yet if it just
you know if I got a phone call then and
my alarm got saved in that state that
would not make me happy yeah likewise
when i'm applying filters and doing a
lot of tweaking um you want to have sort
of a commit step but you shouldn't call
it safe no because that doesn't make any
sense yeah um you should be saving as
you go along in case
because even though you even though the
user hasn't committed they still don't
want to lose work but you do want to get
to a point where you can roll back
essentially yes usually when you're
applying filters like this it's all
logical operations at all mats right
right so while you don't want to have to
keep you know each of those operations
for every photo once you're done you're
done but in terms of being able to save
your progress even before you
permanently alter the image you can just
keep a track of exactly which affects
which filters have been applied save
that and then you can always reapply it
if they come back to the a partir
process has been killed wait so you
should always be prepared for
interruptions even interruptions happen
at a very inconvenient time for you
absolutely but you should never ask the
user to manage storage or to do anything
but commit an action that's already in
progress the only time you want to
surprise a user is with delight not with
annoyance absolutely so this is I mean
you can see when you were when you hit
their camera button it goes to the best
way to the built-in camera so this is
using all of the functionality that you
would have on the standard you know
built-in camera app and then you can
take a photo and then you know lets you
retake it or cancel it or whatever you
want to do so so that's your two
approaches and both of those are
described in the link down there in the
camera topic of the android desire
android developer guides and so they'll
tell you how to use both approaches
let's have a look so the the other thing
we talked about was conforming to the
design guide and so again we kind of
have a few different approaches here
with these apps i think they've pretty
much all except for bloomer done some
form of sort of custom user interface
yep and I think that's I think that's
alright in this circumstance it kind of
makes sense you know you have a
particular ethos of design ethos which
you want to be consistent with on these
apps there are a few little bits and
pieces that I mean I think it probably
my favorite look and feel and it feels
the most consistent the most strongly
branded and I've done a decent job you
know they need to get rid of the legacy
menu button down here they need to make
the drawer conform to our new guidelines
the search here you should probably be
the cynicism we adhere workers off into
its own search this should really just
be using a standard action bar that's
always annoying yeah yeah but i think
you know to a certain extent that's
that's our fault right and these guys
have obviously tried to mimic the action
bar pattern but since our action bar
support library is still not done it
makes it hard stuff absolutely but
that's you know definitely something to
keep in mind and something to look for
its you know where have you seen sort of
these standard patterns and I have to
admit we tend to have a different view
on what a standard pattern is based on
the fact that we're always using the
latest versions of the phones and the
operating systems that is true for us
it's like well I've seen that the
appropriate search action bar thing for
like a year now is it taking people so
long exactly so yeah bear with us better
particularly you know for these guys and
for other people sort of implementing
those sorts of patterns you know you
want search to be simple it's kind of
the key element here right now search is
one two three a tight full and you know
what the terrible two is it it even
looks like you should be able to type
into that right this looks like voice
search bar mean horrible yeah and so you
know if you you know if you take the
alternative approach you know based on
the standard sort of action bar version
is that you will have one button here
and that will expand and then you type
and then you hit enter and you're done
so it's sort of only a couple of actions
and you straight away have it and if you
do it that way build your search into
you know a bunch of ways which make it
easy for you to to leverage that across
the system yeah once again I think the
the feel that I get from this app is
that it had some good people behind it
it's really good design and they ran out
of time and I can tell you exactly where
on every piece of the UI exactly where
they ran out of time and decided screw
it we're going to ship anyway that may
well be the case and in fact we got I
think a fair amount of good response
from the developer strike back show just
yesterday oh so we're going to invite
the guys from I me too to join us next
thursday and see if they can now give us
a bit of feedback on exactly at which
point they got
before they decided they had to ship it
yeah you know what shipping stuff before
it's done is for Microsoft program
managers don't be that guy don't be that
guy all right so do sir I think all of
the apps are pretty good so that's I
think something which was custom
designed that look pretty good i should
mention by the way that I did work for
Microsoft and I just slagging off the
competitor for funds know you've been it
you've done that job that's writing that
guy all right and so this is kind of the
other approach so you're looking at
camera camera effects here and that
again is totally custom but I feel like
here it's not really adding to it it
makes a little bit harder to navigate
how did you understand what's going on
and for not a huge amount of gain this
doesn't look incredible Mexico's targets
are tiny tiny tiny topshop they're
really really difficult to you so yeah
you basically this is a this is a
performance dis improvement exactly this
is going to make it harder for people to
do I mean basically if you've got an app
like this the intention is going to be
that they use this instead of their
camera app so every time they want to
take a photo it's going to be with this
including from within other apps so you
need to make it at least as easy to use
as feature complete as the built-in
camera app which can be tricky but in
terms of you I here in particular you
want to try and make sure that it is
easy to use and certainly not harder and
slowly tease yeah and again can't
emphasize this enough especially for
apps light camera cameras voice
recorders the timers any time that
you're doing something where you may not
actually be looking at the screen
closely or you may not be concentrating
on the UI you it's absolutely critical
that you test on some of these newer
devices that have no hard buttons
because if you look at the camera for
Ruby on picsart we were on a camera
camera on the back sorry I if I'm taking
a picture what am I going to hit what
what button am I going to hit when I
when I try and take that picture it's
going to be sorry we're apparently
getting
boss man stopping by here it's very
strange things happening this corner of
our ice lodge yeah why oh hi I have no
idea who you are okay tool uh let's
let's move on indeed indeed so the next
thing I wanted to point out was around
something which you described earlier so
they're kept stir filters mmm so there's
a bunch of ways you can do this it's all
basically mats and Android actually has
a pretty good tool for making maths work
quickly and that is render script right
arm and so actually Jeff Sharkey gave a
great presentation at i/o this year
which included a big section on how to
use renderscript to perform complicated
computational mathematics and in fact
the example he gave was being able to
start creating mr. filters yep and in
fact I we have a library of them indeed
indeed so that chair check this out and
and that will sort of help you to be
able to get those standard things and
give you the the right processes to be
able to create your own more interesting
and innovative filters as well there's
also some great resources out there if
you're interested in GPU accelerating
renderscript I will actually use the GPU
in some circumstances but you're always
better off just using OpenGL if it's
something that the GV you can handle all
by itself so one of those two or if you
absolutely must drop in to see and use
neon but that's that is that should be
your last resort and the reason it
should be your last resort is because
there is currently Intel phones on the
market there's MIPS phones on the market
you can't guarantee that you're going to
be running on an arm device you could
this year next year it's anybody's game
I think that's one of the advantages of
something like renderscript is that it
really does all of that for you so it's
going to figure i right processor I
infrastructure take it back yeah you
know what you know who wrote renders
kept is it the guys we hired from in
video they were on the CUDA team so
there you go they know their stuff all
right brilliant alright so let's let's
move on the the next piece of advice was
around supporting picasa so i do have as
i think most of these apps did I think
there's one which didn't i'll have to
refresh my memory well nobody because I
we're talking about in general exactly
basically anything which comes up in the
gallery
you can pick to apply a filter to I
expect that to work I expected to be
able to to apply that that filter to any
image which comes back now so would it
be correct to say then what we really
want to do is support image providers
exactly right exactly any image provider
which can end up in my gallery yeah
right because you know this isn't just
about Picasso because says sort of the
default because it ships with the device
um but we encourage everybody to make
image priors and and many OEMs do we
don't actually ship a facebook image
provider as part of Android but many of
the different OEMs you know Samsung
Motorola they have their their own
builds and they have a facebook image
provider I you know Flickr image
provider etc etc so you really want to
be able to work with that so that the
user doesn't see something in the
gallery see something that their phone
is seamlessly offering without saying oh
this is special because it came from
service private or why exactly you see
it all in a big list and then if you
select one and it doesn't work people
are just going to get frustrated by your
exactly and so that's what you want to
get away from now it turns out this is a
not entirely a trivial problem so you
really need to be to look at the URLs or
uris which you get back you know when
you do the picking action I had a quick
look online it turns out we don't have a
great document on how to do this across
sort of the different versions which is
something we should do so I'm going to
put that to our writing team see we can
get something put together in the
meantime I did found this blog post I
haven't you know validated it in detail
I did look like it we're suggesting the
right things so you might want to check
that out and it will give you an idea of
the right way to do that for the food /
caster at least excellent so now the
lack of transparency is going to bite us
yeah it is the other thing which we
mentioned as well is we want these apps
to work on all devices now it turns out
after their latest updates all of these
apps did when I tested them last last
night a couple did not appear to be
installable on my Nexus 7 but this
morning they did so they cater to those
apps which pushed out an update late
last night to make that happen but this
say this link below will take you to a
blog post which will tell you exactly
how to make sure that your app does work
on device if you don't have a back
facing camera now see here is where we
miss the QR code well that's true it's
all a learning curve next week next week
exactly so definitely do do keep that in
mind and so the reason why this is
particularly important for cameras is
because you know there was an assumption
and the very very very early days of
Android that every device would have a
camera was part of an ability test suite
and since that has gradually relaxed
over time to give more opportunities for
differences in hardware we have had to
maintain that assumption that if you are
asking for a camera permission that that
must mean that you need a camera for the
device and that's no longer the case and
so you have to explicitly say hey I know
that I have asked for the permission to
use the camera but even if the camera
isn't there that's fine I'm still happy
to run right you need to mark that
optional in your manifest and in
addition one thing that I personally
find very confusing i think maybe other
people do too is remember that camera in
this case means a rear-facing camera a
front facing camera is something
completely different yeah that's what is
not exam room yeah front-facing camera
not camera and I mean I know there's a
lot of this stuff is going to seem weird
an arbitrary but it's it's really just
there to ensure backwards compatibility
so we're beforehand camera meant
rear-facing camera it just didn't say
that it meant rear-facing camera we
can't change the string because that
will break all of the apps which have
made that assumption beforehand so you
can get a little bit confusing but
that's why backwards compatibility is no
joke so okay so that's basically all of
the things in terms of prescriptions and
the advice there so we've got a couple
of minutes because the neck surgeries
yeah we're doing great I thought we I
thought we were doing an hour today oh
yeah we've got I mean official is about
eight minutes all right well let's get
on the rig off in less than eight
minutes then I think you're sorely
mistaken the whole lightning round so so
this is the prescription so we just
looked at each of these in more detail
so let's take a look at each of the apps
specifically and see how many of these
they are they manage to do today I have
not used green as a way of saying that
I've left it in blue so that it doesn't
disappear into our background okay so
this is this is our first appt I thought
that that was a problem by the way oh
yeah but it was hard to see that that
meant good because it could be any color
based on whatever was behind it quite
true alright so what they did what they
did really well here they offered the
standard muni keeps two filters they
have the community photography which was
really easy and fun to browse through
and it works on devices without camera
so you can just enjoy looking at photos
on whatever device you have and a half
what they didn't do I will support every
image in the gallery so this was the app
where when I click through to try and
apply a filter to something from my
gallery which is all stuck in picasa I
got that I can't access this image so
that would be probably the number one
tip for these guys would be please do
make sure that works we're happy to help
provide the information you need to make
that happen and you know does look great
without contradicting the design guide I
gave that one a yellow just because you
know if there's a couple of little thing
the search bar the draw pattern the the
menu button those sorts of things there
they reimplemented the action bar which
is always tricky because you're going to
get something wrong and even if you get
it perfectly right you're going to get
broken by the next version so hopefully
they can move over to your
actionbarsherlock grab action bar app
compat and start using something that
the google's supporting directly and
that'll make their their app easier to
maintain I think exactly so I think this
was a grown-up I really loved it I can
see why it's so popular I think if you
add that support for picasa or four
generic images in the gallery then I
think you're onto a real winner second
app we looked at was picsart again so
this stick almost all of the boxes it
supports every image it offers the
standard and unique hipster filters
you've got the community stuff there
works on devices with our cameras so
it's pretty good again I gave it a
yellow against the design guide you know
in this case they've done the they've
done the action bar correctly they've
got the search filters and everything
else I think where I got a little more
concerned was around things like the
camera which again they've got the
custom UI doesn't see
be adding along and the shutter button
is not only tiny but directly next to
the home button where my thumb will very
easily slide over an area that very bad
idea so that's you know that's a concern
and I also found that once once I
started sort of tunneling into this up a
little bit more it started to get a
little more difficult to navigate a
little harder to understand what the
navigation patterns were what some of
the usability stuff was so they've done
a really good job on the front page but
it sort of starts to go downhill a
little bit after that once you never get
past that first home screen do you fight
you right but i will say that they did a
great job on their image list they looks
really really pretty so that's a great
example of the right way to do that so
uh yeah nicely done absolutely third
appt was glimmer so this was the the
flickreviewr softer that gets red dots
for anything to do with applying filters
because that's not what this app does
that's a little unfair yeah I was gonna
I was going to existing we should be a
black dot washing white dog you just
remove them right get them out of there
cuz it's not really appropriate but it
does it does look right it was great
looking you I it's all about the
community of photographers works on any
device again it's a much more simple
after some of the others we looked at
today but they've gone done a really
good job with what's left early all
right and Anna last off we looked at
camera and zoom FX so this didn't have
the community of photography didn't have
that ability to see other photos that
people are taken with the grid happen I
don't know I like it if for no other
reason then it shows you what's possible
with a camera phone and with their app
so it's kind of great advertising for
your own app if you were if you have
that in there and similarly the the
design guide issues were a little bit
questionable in terms of how much value
are you adding by creating this new skin
for your FLIR camera you know really
small icons a little bit blurry so I
think they can do a little bit there to
really
you know really make it a lot I much
better app so that's all that's the salt
we wanted to look at in terms of apps
today without I think three or four
minutes left to go which is nice we are
going to pass on each of the apps we've
looked at today to the guys at aroma
Nick and Adam to look at in Android
design in action on Tuesday at ten
thirty so definitely check that out I'm
not sure which acts they're planning to
look on Lookout today but will be
amongst those four and keep an eye on
the Android developers Plus page will
announce exactly which apps those are
hopefully later today absolutely once
again join us next thursday when
developers strike back against both rato
myself and roman and his crew and see
what they think of the suggestions
criticisms and potentially new designs
that's that we've suggested to them so
make sure if you are one of the
developers we talked about today do make
sure we have a way to get in contact
with you so we can invite you to the
show and if you one of our viewers and
have questions for the developers again
let us know in the comments to the
events to the G+ event and we'll be sure
to put those questions to the developers
when we have them live via hangout in
the studio now if you're a game
developer or you like games or you like
beer or your bed ridden and just have
nothing else to do I don't forget that
the Friday games review is happening
again today and has also moved to
another time we're doing that at noon
pacific so in just about half an hour
and daniel galpin and myself excellent
be doing that i'll change from my lab
coat into my my hoodie and we'll get
down we'll get jiggy will do game stuff
I'm concerned that you went the Red Bull
hearing the wrong show you think maybe
and I think maybe you did or maybe
that's when the mountains you don't you
you don't even know I'm like I'm kicking
it Elvis style alright this is the you
gotta get right in the middle yeah
alright nice any of you guys gonna match
levels I think it's less about getting a
red bull for yourself and maybe get
a valium that's a maybe tremor yeah
we'll see yeah all right that's pretty
much it for us we going to look at
travel booking and planning apps next
week in the app clinic absolutely right
that we're getting ready for the
holidays so we figure everybody travels
during the holiday either to be with
family or to get away from family so
true that it's about time to start
booking those flights we're going to
look at booking apps and then later on
we're going to look at travel apps as in
apps to help you when you're on the road
is that make sure you get that right so
you currency converter zet cetera later
for tomorrow for next week we want to
have apps which help you make bookings
helps you figure out where to go those
sorts of things absol so yeah definitely
give us your suggestions in the
moderator page and tune in the same time
as this week next week this is going to
be the new time unless it turns out that
we've been talking to an audience of
three where we may reconsider that's
pretty much it from us thank you very
much for joining us at the new time and
and thank you for everyone who nominated
apps and voted for them without that we
would have a pretty boring show or at
least perhaps more boring than it
already is alright my name is reto Meier
I'm here needless and we will see you
all next week yeah
you